hey there have you ever wondered how you
can optimize your software development
process through the power of cloud
computing and Java in this era of
digital transformation every
organization is looking for a way to
improve their services and processes and
cloud computing has become a key
solution to many of these challenges so
if you are a Java developer it's time
for you to explore the world of Java on
cloud Java is highly scalable and
versatile programming platform that is
suitable for a wide range of
applications and with cloud computing
it's not possible to run Java
application on a virtual platform in the
cloud the benefits are numerous from
cost saving to improved scalability and
availability Java on cloud is a game
changer for developers like you in this
video we will help you understand why
Java is such an excellent choice for
cloud computing we will cover topics
like development strategies travel
shooting and optimization tips we will
also guide you through the different
types of cloud platforms that you can
work with and how to optimize your code
for efficient cloud computing so whether
you are new to the world of Java on
cloud or an experienced developer
looking to take your skill to the next
level this video is a must watch our
comprehensive guide will help you
navigate the landscape of Java on cloud
and make most of your exciting
technology don't miss out on this
opportunity to learn more about Java on
cloud a video will give you a deep
understanding of how to optimize your
Java application for the cloud and how
to be ahead of the curve in this
emerging field
so let's learn together
but before that cloud game building is a
highly technical field and having a
right certification can set you apart
from the competition consider getting
certified in the popular cloud computing
platforms like AWS Azure or Google Cloud
now to help you with this step we have a
Caltech postgraduate program in cloud
computing this course will help you
become an expert in Azure AWS and gcp
and let you master fundamental
architecture principle and develop the
skill needed to become a cloud expert
this postgraduate program in cloud
computing will help you become an expert
in designing planning and scaling Cloud
implementation after completing this
course you will gain Caltech ctm a
postgraduate certificate with 40 plus
Hands-On projects you can check out the
link in the description box below Java
is a popular programming language known
for its flexibility reliability and
extensive ecosystem of library and
Frameworks on the other hand Google
Cloud provides a reverse platform
through hosting and learning Java
application allowing developers to
Leverage The scalability reliability and
performance benefit of the cloud now
Google Cloud offers several services and
tools to support Java development and
deployment the first one on our list is
app engine
Apple app engine is fully managed
platform as a service offering that
allows you to develop Java application
without worrying about infrastructure
management it automatically scales your
application demand provides built-in
security features and supports popular
Java Frameworks like springboard next we
have compute engine
compute engine provides virtual machines
vvms that allows you to run Java pin
with complete control over the
underlying infrastructure you can
customize the VM configuration install
any required software or libraries and
optimize the Performance Based on your
specific needs now we have it engine
cumulate engine is managed container or
gestation platform that enables you to
deploy scale and manage Java application
using Docker containers it provides a
scalable and resistant infrastructure
for running Java application allowing
you to leverage features like Auto
scaling load balancing and rolling
updates next we have Cloud functions
Cloud function is a seamless Computing
platform that allows you to write and
deploy Java functions in response to
events with Cloud functions you can
focus on writing code without worrying
about infrastructure management it
automatically scales your function and
charges U only for the actual execution
time when deploying Java application on
Google Cloud you can leverage various
two services to optimize your code
troubleshooting issues and ensure
efficient cloud computing now let's dive
into an explanation of working with Java
on Google Cloud covering development
strategies optimization tips and
different Cloud platforms let's start
with development strategies the first
one is app engine Google app engine
allows you to develop your Java
application as a fully managed service
it handles scaling monitoring and
maintenance of your application you can
deploy your application using the app
engine flexible environment which offers
more flexibility in terms of runtime and
dependency or the app engine standard
environment next we have kubernet engine
if you prefer containerizing development
Google kubernet engine is a powerful
option it allows you to develop your
Java application as a containers managed
by kubernetes gke provides Auto scaling
load balancing and easy management of
containerizing workloads next we have
compute engine for more control and
flexibility you can develop your
application of Java on Google compute
engine compute engine provides virtual
machines on which you can install and
configure your Java application
according to your requirements now let's
talk about troubleshooting the first one
is logs and monitoring Google Cloud
provides logging and monitoring tools
like Google Cloud logging and Cloud
monitoring you can use these tools to
collect and analyze logs Track
Performance metrics and troubleshoot
issues in your Java application
next we have error reporting Google
Cloud error reporting automatically
collects and Aggregates error from your
Java application it provides insights
into the root cause of Errors helping
you identify and fix issues quickly next
is stackdiver debugger start driver
debugger allow you to inspect the state
of your Java application at any code
location without stopping or slowing it
down
you can also set breakpoints and lock
custom debugging information enabling
you to troubleshoot issues in real time
let's discuss optimization tips
first is scaling
configure automatic scaling for your
application to handle varying workloads
app engines and gke offers built-in
scaling features that can automatically
adjust the number of instant containers
based on demand
next is caching utilizing caching
machinerism like Google Cloud memory
store or Cloud CDN to reduce latency and
improve performance by caching
frequently Access Data next is database
optimization if your Java application
relies on a database consider using
Google Cloud SQL or Google Cloud spanner
on manage and scalable database Services
optimize database queries using indexes
effectively and consider data sharp
Technologies to distribute data and
improve performance next we have cost
optimization utilize Google Cloud's cost
optimization features such as right
sizing instances and leveraging auto
scaling to optimize cost based on actual
demands lastly let's explore different
Cloud platform options the first one is
Google app engine a fully managed
platform that allows you to deploy and
scale application without worrying about
infrastructure management next we have
Google kubernet engine a managed
kubernetes service for deploying
managing and scaling container arising
application
third one is Google compute engine
provides virtual machines for running
application with control over the
infrastructure configuration and
scalability options
next one is Google Cloud functions a
serverless execution environment where
you can deploy Java functions that
automatically scales based on event
triggers
the last one is Google Cloud run a
serverless platform that allows you to
run containerizing applications in any
event-driven manner now to optimize your
code for efficient cloud computing
consider leverage asynchronous
programming offload computational
intensive tasks use Services optimize
network communication and also use
caching remember that optimizing code
for cloud computing involves a
combination of architecture decisions
infrastructure configuration and
codeless optimization it's important to
understand the specific requirements and
constraints of your application and
Leverage The Available tools and
services provided by the cloud platform
to achieve Optimal Performance and cost
efficiently so with this we have reached
the end of this video make sure to like
and video And subscribe to Simply learns
YouTube channel thank you staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign